russia and ukraine united in rivalry in
the interview Kremlin critic and former
oligarch mikhail khodorkovsky lisbon
Khodorkovsky no it's in the district or
Tokarski let's start with the situation
in Ukraine 50 a week on that the recent
D Day commemorations in France there
were informal meetings between US
President Barack Obama Russia's Vladimir
Putin and Petro poroshenko the newly
elected ukrainian President the German
Polish and Russian foreign ministers
also met in st. Petersburg the West sees
this as a step towards possible
rapprochement what's your assessment HD
epic on yin yoga chance to sign contains
10 must be negotiations but I wish to
see towards safe kotori the situation in
Ukraine is serious enough ok inna Anakin
is now which is closed now but President
Putin has also maneuvered himself into a
most delicate and complicated
predicament he yes Leah if both sides
remain unwilling to talk the results
could be disastrous Russia bid thee gym
Dasha takatori she wouldn't emit mr.
[ __ ] we do later is there any
possibility that the Kremlin can somehow
come to terms with the new government in
Kiev alas de lea or will the threat of
draconian sanctions somehow force
Russia's hand is the image of the dealer
smooth little yes opposed to it neither
as those things matter this circles the
only important issue is what Putin
things Putin nuh how much does this was
not there's no doubt that he has a whole
series of measures that he wants to
impose on Ukraine or slowly cut auto
bunker hill and if Kiev accept them
Putin will put an end to some of the
pressures he's been exerting that you're
slowly open door hmm poor girls but
under those circumstances at it
materially I doubt that Ukraine would
remain a sovereign nation as much it
oak reyna ostalos miseries Mongoose
uderstand en eterno Yellin the Western
on the other hand nice omnia counter
strategies might help to correct Putin's
demands it was with the result of an
acceptable outcome for both sides to
court you were not a hundred percent
convinced himself that sanctions are the
best motivator to the universe John
Mostow present of Ukraine and Russia
must resolve their differences on their
own terms pushing Turkish [ __ ] of New
Trier Isis cadila Ganesha motoki Irish
at seminar odom mashup if Ukraine really
desires freedom and sovereignty yes Lee
okay it must be willing to find some of
the history in each other do ye producer
wat states who might even elite charity
the Russian presidents overriding goal
is pursuing the vision of a Eurasian
Union his response to the European Union
a kind of counterbalance nemeth that
would be awesome and to make the dream a
reality student needs Ukraine or at
least part of it is that his prime
motivation at Valley waits at it were
pray it yet or do because there doesn't
matter what his motivation was the
problem is that his strategy for Ukraine
has spawned massive negative
consequences for Russia disti billion
Ukrainian negative anomaly Russia is a
very attractive country of mr. was more
in Eurasia it's the recognized leader in
terms of Technology and science worship
European willing Russia should exploit
these advantages technique in ocean and
the sea should have formed alliances
with our neighbors that would strengthen
all sides the bits Abedini evoke rocks
instead yeah Putin has achieved the
exact opposite vittoria stool aburras
mozna Abedini nasha stronger economic
relations a fairly solid with most
Eurasian nations you can image gives a
machine years Lamia
sure but that's mostly due to the sheer
lack of alternatives what's this module
which noctem starts since Ukraine
diplomatic relations with these
countries have deteriorated drastically
support ya got as the horribly did
tensions are high throughout the region
and mistrust has grown exponentially
mistrust both of Russia and ethnic
Russians who live in those countries
Shores are prime examples are the Baltic
States mr Wood no gross this is directly
tied to Putin's policies not sure you
can you envision 30 which would it may
sound unfair but my opinion is justified
yeah boo skuzzle Vladimir Putin has made
broad promises but has delivered very
little he has duped millions of Russians
but still millionaire sheehan okay wit
school what about Crimea it's clear
Russia won't hand it back to Ukraine and
the West refuses to recognize the
annexation creamer will Crimea remain a
thorn in the side of relations between
Russia and the Western alliance is upper
them CLP yet or do bitching store again
see I'm convinced that Russia and
Ukraine must find a way to work together
steady skip would you missed you
eventually Porsche me so the two nations
are indivisible as the loomis resume nor
producer we must travel the same path on
the international stage and in relations
with Europe must be durable a Dutch
nerve europa y rom code that's the only
way to solve the crimea dispute which
native tongue he attack a problem okok
problema crema acaricia tales with the
reserve of numerous reasons i want to
hear your opinion about the clash of
cultures and about the apparent
rejection of the western lifestyle you
know Asia kaziri yet balanced I'm
talking about tolerance of alternative
sexuality freedom of speech
individuality and egotism ageism
jiu-jitsu team collectivism can Russian
society except these values reason if
the
mr. on reseda cisco option roscoe
cha'aka premium Oh Marcie yenye amenia
engine Russians are every bit as much
individualists as the citizens of
Western Europe yet but there's cos
ulster son go so far as to say that a
collective spirit is far more widespread
in the West Eve were the mud that is
precisely the problem we Russians have
matzo we simply can't unite even when it
comes to finding solutions to
contentious issues by me Margot
Siddhartha those are really am at GRC it
is vitally important to formulate
alliances independent of government
power brokers literacy enya the stars-
lint agree roots but so many Russians
have already emigrated what's up Nostra
he needs with the millions a living in
the West discomfort anoka multitude
leave Jacob they have integrated
seamlessly into Western society with
ease otsuka premier with Wiz negotiate
they'll find a Russian Chinatown's now
Russian districts in western cities
suddenly get the ketosis they also semi
me lose me knockin boots resist what
about Russian quirks traditions what the
move is it true that Russians would
rather be feared than loved by Alice yes
[ __ ] they stood opposites in reality
that translates into weakness and
insecurity ercan at the gift shop kissy
there are so many Russians who believe
in themselves in their ability to
compete and in their inherent strengths
they understand that Russia is a part of
Europe and they also recognize their
status as equals with Europe Russia will
not tolerate being treated as a small
child Russian culture is closely tied
with Europe's y en la prova bullets
without Russian influence European
culture would be entirely different
equal to Y desdra Ziska cultura y
pisciculture Rose Bowl assertion drugoi
if you take a [ __ ] liquid how can we
resolve these differences
machine you do you've said that there
are very few free-thinking liberal
voices in Russia better than us throwing
it you've also said that the vast
majority of Russians are afraid to speak
their minds what can be done to combat
the government-run media vamos sur le at
the moment we don't have too many
alternatives over the end of our Billu
Jean other than this vital that our
citizens are well informed prekrasno pin
you might store and Putin's regime
understands that it can only retain
control of important information nene
azami when that control is exerted as
discreetly as possible once more at
Saqqara need us why you would sway
control adopts tow each barrier Russian
television is completely under
government control economica propones
John the Swedish engine hood but print
media is increasingly under pressure as
well control and there have been
attempts to regulate the internet to
such as which in seriousness to play
near as your knife internet but modern
technology is making it easier to break
down these barriers yeah buddy yeah yeah
open your Prezi modules and we must keep
doing search in Russia or SEM Russians
and a part of Western society that just
face a United task and that is to fight
for the Russian people and their ideals
0cm as a Western nations should support
this battle we need to chest you a
terrible check yet the problem yes
liqueur equivalent suka cranium ukraine
has chosen to ally itself with Europe
yum the older let's say it builds a
functioning vibrant democracy based on
law and order with us and european
support so that's not a mine in series
over there if and how would that affect
russia would it be seen as an
opportunity or a threat but it's gentes
getting over over there Lydia make me
some young no gross the Putin regime
would undoubtedly see it as a threat
mario's new era but from Russia it would
be a fantastic blueprint sister not sure
close to India
it would be wonderful to see a
prosperous and satisfied Ukraine what it
especially since we have such close ties
Luda turkeys record it might function as
a paradigm booty the precedent is a
touching that the people so close to us
in terms of language and culture that
have achieved success building the
foundations of democracy that outcome
could truly provide a blueprint for
similar renewal in Russia prabhas miss
Newcombe pretty areum espera she is a
masterpiece last question which teams do
you want to see in the world cup final
which infinity mirror wicket in belize
finale mm-hmm was late it I'm not a
soccer fan but like every Russian I want
to see our team in the final against
Brazil's will be visit rasiya I should
present first thank you Russia spasiba